bonjour jean françois di mailhiot merci
de retour sur arte france à nos
questions je baille donne est donc allé
au pentagone
et il a annoncé la création d'un groupe
de travail pour définir la stratégie
ferme face à la chine ça veut dire quoi
exactement
probablement qu'il n'y en avait pas donc
c'est une reprise en main de la sueur et
plus pratique à l'époque de train qui
qu'on se souvienne trump s'était déclaré
un grand habit qingping puis qu'ensuite
il avait eu r et guerre commerciale
donc ce qui va être rétablie fait bien
sûr une rationalité et cohérence à joe
biden veut mettre l'accent sur le
respect des droits humains qui ne simba
fois en chine quelle marge de manoeuvre
selon vous pour lui l'a déjà en parler
c'est extrêmement important puisque
jusqu'à présent beaucoup de dirigeants
occidentaux sont très timides sur ce
sujet là la discussion des pays d'europe
de l'ouest et des vingt-sept aussi
qu'ils auraient gosses ils traités
d'investissement avec la chine ont
mentionné bien sûr besoin d'améliorer la
situation en chine en particulier aussi
tient aussi à hong kong mais rarement de
façon aussi ferme et en incluant flare
dans les conditions du dialogue avec
pékin
et pourquoi selon vous en parler
maintenant pourquoi est-ce que ça
n'avait pas été évoqué
plus tôt après effectivement du point de
vue américain on était comme je les dis
dans une position qui est une position
d'opposition frontale sur des sujets qui
étaient des sujets commerciaux et qui
ensuite étaient des sujets extrêmement
généreuse qu'abidal choisi de faire est
effectivement de rationaliser la
relation bien sûr de la rétablir de
trouver des champs de dialogue et vous
l'avez mentionné c'est le sujet
sanitaire le sujet environnemental qui
sont des sujets hippique du
multilatéralisme
mais il faut aussi ajouter ce qui n'a
pas été du cerveau dans votre
commentaire que le la qualication les
qualificatifs que biden a utilisé après
cette communication téléphonique avec
bing ping s'est il n'a pas une once de
démocratie et donc clairement byden se
pose au début de son mandat comme le
défenseur des démocraties occidentales
par opposition aux hommes qui eux ne
mettent pas les droits de l'homme en
premier lieu les jeunes médecins en
premier lieu et le fait de parler de
cela est que c'est pas aussi un côté une
part d'ingérence de la part des états
unis joe biden
c'est une affirmation des valeurs
américaines les valeurs occidentales et
bien sûr en chine on dira toujours qu'il
s'agit d'une ingérence mais si on veut
avoir un dialogue on doit se parler
franchement et je pense que la partie
chinoise liu qui est ce terme de
dialogue franc justement par le dialogue
franc un job hayden a dit à l'instant
que l'entretien téléphonique a duré deux
heures entre lui et xi jingping sans son
homologue ça veut dire quoi se dire
qu'il ya eu un dialogue franc comme vous
le dites que tous les points même ce qui
fâche le plus ont été abordés ou est-ce
que c'est simplement une manière de
communiquer indirecte de façade
nous non c'est important dans ses
poursuivants important au début du
mandat
il a été préparé les ministres des
affaires étrangères dans benken d'un
côté et où en guise de l'autre avaient
préparé par leurs propres coups de
téléphone qui avait anticipé cette
communication
il avait donc établi l'agenda une fois
qu'ils avaient établi cet agenda
la communication a été possible
il a été possible effectivement que
parce qu'on avait identifiées tous les
sujets et ne pouvaient être que donc
parce qu'on est au début bien sûr eu des
phobies chauffe ou machine est aussi
qu'elle est longue parce que on est dans
une situation où les rencontres
physiques sont quand même relativement
difficile et donc on essaie de mettre au
maximum les sujets dans ce genre de dans
ce genre de contacts bien sûr deux
heures c'est long gardons en tête aussi
qu'ils aient le temps de
l'interprétariat ça n'est pas deux
heures continue ou on va se parler
pendant deux heures les interprètes
intervienne justement vous dites on est
au début d'une relation le mandat de
bayonne va durer quatre ans qu'est-ce
qu'il faut attendre au cours de ce
mandat sur les différents points au
niveau de la guerre commerciale
notamment certainement pas un changement
d'orientation par rapport à attraper en
ce qui concerne les priorités
commerciales états unis un changement de
ton certainement mais aussi une énorme
incertitude parce que vous l'avez dit
dès le début de mandat de quatre ans
mais c'est peut-être aussi le début d'un
seul mandat de quatre ans donc il ya
beaucoup d'incertitudes qui pèsent sur
cette communication et sur
l'établissement des relations
diplomatiques byden va est allié avec
ses contreparties qui vont très souvent
de configurer comme président de
transition parce que vu son âge il est
très peu probable qu'il se représente
même s'il en a l'occasion
au bout de quatre ans il a en face de
lui un vrai outil dont on ignore le
terme et un soutien pin dont on ignore
encore plus ce terme dans son allocution
joe biden a également annoncé vouloir
prendre des sanctions contre les
généraux birmans après leur coup d'état
qui a renversé l'ex dirigeante option
sotchi joe biden
là aussi veut s'ingérer dans les
affaires internationales en début de
mandat ce qui est certain c'est que
contrairement au retrait général les
affaires du monde que trump avait opéré
hayden va pouvoir de nouveau être de
représentants d'un certain nombre de
valeurs et sans vouloir être le gendarme
du monde il a bien dit qu'il ne
souhaitait pas être le gendarme du monde
il faudra effectivement mentionné la
position américaine sur un certain
nombre de sujets il ne faut pas oublier
par ailleurs que tout ça va être mitigé
par la nécessité s'occuper des affaires
intérieures
donc bien sûr cette volonté et
glisse-t-elle volonté sera manifestée
quelle sera la réalité de fait que vous
appelez cette ingérence ou en tout cas
cet intérêt pour les affaires du monde
c'est encore à voir tant que la pandémie
est pas réglée aux états unis merci jean
françois di milieu d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
président de l'institut de recherche
asia center